una década de democracia en mianmar
terminó el 1º de febrero de 2021 y lanzó
al país a una sangrienta agitación
política
la líder civil onza en su chip de 76
años y ganadora del premio nobel de paz
fue derrocada y detenida por los
militares para cederle el poder al jefe
de las fuerzas armadas el general vino
online en la mayor muestra de
descontento desde 2007 miles de
ciudadanos se tomaron las calles de la
nación dando inicio a una espiral de
violencia que aún no termina en la
conmemoración del día de las fuerzas
armadas y el mar vivió su día más del
sangriento con 160 víctimas el primero
de abril sus y enfrentó su primera
acusación por violar la ley de secretos
oficiales ya ha sido condenada a seis
años de cárcel pero los múltiples cargos
que enfrenta podrían darle una condena
combinada de más de 150 años los
esfuerzos del bloque de la asociación de
naciones de asia suroriental para
encontrar una salida diplomática no han
dado frutos la junta militar apenas ha
mencionado la posibilidad de unas
elecciones en 2020
en un año de golpe militar se estima que
alrededor de 1500 opositores a la junta
han sido asesinados y otros 1.800
detenidos según la asociación de
asistencia a los presos políticos
naciones unidas dice que 320 mil
personas han sido desplazadas y 6,2
millones necesitan asistencia
humanitaria urgente y el banco mundial
cree que la economía se ha contraído un
30 por ciento como consecuencia directa
del golpe que también habría borrado un
millón de puestos de trabajo un año del
golpe que llega acompañado de sanciones
de eeuu canadá y reino unido- y con
renovados llamados a la resistencia de
la población civil movilizaciones que ya
han sido amenazadas con más de represión
[Música]